[Music]
hello Su TV family and friends we
welcome you to one of our favorite shows
I'd like to know this is our Bible
question and answer show where we get
the privilege of answering your
questions finding out those things that
are on your mind and in your heart and
going to the word of God which is
something we love to do my name is CA
Murray I'm in the company of two fellow
Travelers on the road to glory to my
right Pastor Steven bore president and
founder of this wonderful Ministry and
to my left Pastor David Salazar who
superintends our work in the Latino area
the Latino Channel and does so many many
things he is a jack of all trades and uh
and a master of many also uh and we're
happy to have him
here gentlemen we're going to uh go into
our questions but before we do we want
to have a word of prayer which I will
ask you Pastor Salazar to do and I will
remind you and encourage you in the
strongest possible terms to send in your
questions to tvom
tv.org that is TV at susum as in Mary
tv.org and we promise we will get to
your questions just as soon as we
possibly can something we like to do so
if you don't see your question maybe a
couple days after you send it in hold on
stick with us we will get to it and we
make you that promise Pastor if you
would pray for us let's let's pray
Heavenly Father we come before you to
humbly ask for the inspiration and the
discernment of the holy spirit that we
may receive the instruction from you
that the answers that we may present
today they may come from your word and
may bring people closer to you to a
deeper understanding of the scriptures
and to show them uh the beauty of the
Bible how it can answer our questions
can answer our inquiries and how it can
bring us closer to you to the truth and
to the light uh be with us now we thank
you for your grace and we pray this in
Jesus name amen amen and amen Teresa is
our first questioner the first person
and Teresa you start out your question
by saying something that is music to the
of any Pastor you say your program has
been a blessing to me that's what we
love to hear that what we do our work
that we put in is blessing and is
allowing a person to be blessed the
question you asked um we are having a
study today in church on the question of
whether or not God created evil but
there was a disagreement where some
believe that God created evil when he
created choice I do not believe this how
would you respond to this she is
probably referring to Isaiah 45 verse 7
Pastor do you have it or Pastor do you
have it who has it I've got it okay if
you would read that for us Isaiah 45:7
says go God is speaking I form the light
and create Darkness I make peace and
create
Calamity I the Lord do all these things
the King James says I create evil uhhuh
yeah so part of the answer is in what
you just read right
it's it's a lot of it is in the
translation I went through about a half
a dozen translations and most of them
say Calamity some say disaster but most
of them say Calamity the only one that
says evil is the King James and that has
confus a lot of people uh because of
that translation Pastor you want to add
anything to that yeah uh in James uh 1
verse 13 it says this let no one say
when he is tempted I am tempted by by
God for God cannot be tempted by evil
nor does he himself tempt anyone so you
know I think that is the Bible is clear
in in indicating that Temptation or evil
it's is not something that originates in
God at all it's uh evil
and sin originated in someone else that
was Lucifer the the angel that God had
given all the opportunities to be and to
continue to be the one near the Throne
of God but because of as Isaiah and
Ezekiel mentions very well you know what
happened in his heart he changed in his
heart he started to to have this
covetousness for the Lord and pride
filled his heart and so because of his
pride because of his covetousness of the
position of Christ and and and of the of
the the worship that the god received he
started with evil or his heart turned
into evil and furthermore the spirit of
Prophecy and I have a quote here from um
this is actually found in uh review and
her and I want to read to you how the
spirit prophecy mentions in regards to
the this experience of of of of the Lord
it says here
um this is ran
Herald August 4th 19 1910 it says evil
sin and death were not created by God
they are the result of Disobedience
which originated in
Satan so and then she says but the
knowledge of evil now in the world was
brought in through the cunning of Satan
so it's it's very clear that anything
that comes from you know that sin evil
or anything that's that's that's
including death all of those elements
came or originated through the Lucifer
through Satan departing from God and
making himself you know one like wanting
to be like God establishing this
parallel system of government to the
Lord what particularly concerns me about
the last part of this question MH is uh
where it says but there was a
disagreement where some believe that God
created evil when he created choice that
that's the part that's troubling in
other words God should have created us
without Choice yes and then there would
be no evil yeah but what would happen if
uh God had created us without Choice
what would be the implications of that
we'll just be slaves robots you know
without really any will true love has to
be volitional if I'm going to love God
I've got to choose to love him he can't
make your wife um who stood by her side
all those years if she was forced to
love you
then that's a little different you know
she's with you because she loves you she
would have been miserable the last 53
years oh hallelujah amen but but but you
understand my point that that that that
true love has to be has to be given by
choice it cannot be forced it cannot be
coerced um and so when when you love
somebody you run the risk of Your Love
not being returned which is what God has
been dealing with for 7,000 years
um you love them and you express your
love and Jalisa says well I don't want
to bother with you but what do you do
you go someplace else but God has no
place else to go he has no one else to
turn to he loves us uh he is love he
does love he keeps on loving yeah and
he's in he's in the in the soup with us
just like he's in in pain he's suffering
just like we are so he chose to make us
free moral agents and that
presupposed a risk but of course he had
the answer to the risk which was which
was Christ dying on the cross which
another question we'll get to a little
bit later so no uh choice and and and
and sin are not the same and should not
be equated maybe we could phrase it this
way God created man mhm with the
potential of choosing evil yes or with
the possibility of choosing evil but God
didn't make the choice amen so the human
agent is responsible for misre misusing
Choice uh you know there's another point
that we must bring in here which we've
answered in previous questions and that
is that in the Bible what God
allows is attributed to him God has a
causitive will where he directly does it
and he has a permissive will where he
allows it to happen yes and the pl prime
example that I find of this is in uh uh
The Book of Job I think it puts it all
together the first two chapters tell us
that who brought all of the evil upon
job Lucifer that was Satan Satan I mean
yeah Satan brought all of the evil on
job it's clear in chapter 1 and chapter
two very true however at the end of the
chapter of chapter 42 at the end of the
book it says then all his brothers all
his sisters and those who had been his
AC acquaintances before came to him and
ate food with him in his house and they
consoled him and comforted him for all
the adversity that the Lord had brought
upon
himh well we know the Lord didn't bring
the all of these things upon job yes he
allowed he gave permission for Satan to
do it precisely and we have other
examples of this in the Bible it says in
2 Thessalonians 2 that God will bring
upon them a strong delusion that should
believe a lie that sounds like God is
leading people to believe
lies but really what God it says they
didn't want to receive the love of the
truth that was their choice therefore
God leaves them to the strong delusion
that they should be believe the lie
instead of the truth and uh you know we
have many examples of this in the Bible
2 Chronicles 18 you know where you have
the story of uh Ahab going to battle and
the false prophets uh telling uh King
Ahab yeah you should go to battle you
know you're G going to gain a big big
victory and the passage describes a
council in heaven where Satan uh is
given permission by God to convince the
false prophets to convince Ahab to go to
battle so the Bible is very clear that
God does not create evil in the sense
that we understand it God actually
creates human beings with freedom of
choice and they choose they have the
potential for choosing evil mhm they
have the potential or the possibility of
choosing evil and if they do they're to
blame not God yes once you make a
certain Choice there are certain
inevitabilities that follow with that
choice um Proverbs 13:15 says the way of
the transgressor is hard so if you if
you turn your back on God you're in for
hard times you can't blame God uh
because God says uh choose life choose
me and live uh obey and live disobey and
die so your your choices
aim you if I can say that in a certain
direction uh for good or or for ill and
of course the translation Calamity which
is used in the version the new King
James that I read they're trying to
escape the
implications of God creating evil so
they translate Calamity uh that God
brings Calamity but even when God brings
Calamity he does it in two ways he's
going to pour out the seven last plagues
mhm you know that's the biggest Calamity
mhm but God also allows the devil to
cause calamities yes you know Ellen
White says that he he he knows the
secrets of the Laboratories of nature he
can he can cause nature to cause
destruction and desolation because God
allows it so we need to understand that
God allows and God causes uh but God is
Not ultimately responsible for all the
bad things that happen yeah I've got a
sermon series and I'm coming to you
David uh uh five part series what were
when one were how when were who
uh and were no more the first one
asserts that the Lord and the devil will
both use stress and Punishment in your
life but for different reasons God will
will put you under the gun sometimes to
get your attention sometimes to save
your soul when he when he gets your
attention he will he will release the
the fire he'll turn down the flame the
devil will turn up the flame just
because he wants to see you dance he
wants to see you in the flame so it's
different so when you're when you're in
an adversary situation one of the first
things you must determine is where is
this coming from is something that God
is allowing or is it just punishment
from the devil because anytime you try
to do good you're going to be opposed by
the devil so it could be that or it
could be the Lord allowing you to to
suffer a little bit because he's trying
to get your attention so that there's
there's that kind of thing yeah I just
wanted to add to the you know this that
I think sometimes people
misunderstand the the justice of God and
they think that he operates if he brings
some sort of Calamity it's out of spite
or because he Delights in the you know
in the dead of the in the people and
it's not like that all the acts of God
have um have a cause and and even his
acts of justice of punishment if you
will are motivated by Justice and by
Mercy so we have to understand that in
the light of how God executes judgment
it's not because he's just run out of
love let's put it that way you know he
he's not like that he actually has given
enough evidence enough time and he has
been longsuffering but eventually as
they have rejected God as as people have
turned their hearts away from God the
the result for him to finish or put an
end to evil he has to execute judgment
happened in the in the flood you know he
brought the flood because the people had
been so wicked that it was the only way
that he could sort of reset this this
earth and the SC would not hold you know
take a hold of every single individual
being and happened with there was a lot
of s and gomorah and even in the times
of Jerusalem Israel the destruction of
Jerusalem because they had been so
rebellious so evil in their hearts so we
have to see that when the Lord or the
Bible speaks of God acting in a way that
seems contrary to his loving character
is not he is not running out of love is
actually an action based on his mercy
and his Justice which are part of his
own character amen amen and amen now
gentlemen I'm looking at the clock on
the wall I'm going to exercise the no
bless that comes to sitting in this
chair and jump over question 36 because
I see where this is going to take up the
rest of our time and go to question 037
because we mayble to answer this a
little bit shorter all right and get
this 37 also is going to be too long so
why don't we go to 38
he's pulling rank on me
okay you are of course correct the court
of appeal has
overturned hello greetings I I love uh
to know the Christian stand on polygamy
okay we we can kind of run through this
the vict the victims lie with the
Africans according to the church
doctrine the poly the polygamists aren't
baptized and do not enjoy Holy Communion
besides
evangelism what is the biblical Doctrine
on this do the polygamists have hope
when they believe in their in their
election in Christ do they do they go
about their current polygamy State the
first thing I want to say uh because I
we've dealt with this at the general
conference level when I was on general
conference committee and I know you guys
have dealt with this before mhm you
always have hope because polygamy is not
the unpardonable sin right it's just
once what you do once you find yourself
in that state so well Abraham was
polygamous indeed he was many many of
the Bible Heroes were polygamous doesn't
mean that it was God's ideal no
right so so what what hope do we give
him because there is
hope and and you know Pastor I think
that also important that we answer
question 41 that is in regards to this
particular case and I think it's you
know maybe you can read that one so we
can answer both questions because uh
Jason has send this question and and it
will be good to read that question as
well so we can answer them both at the
same time idea
Jason
uh can a Muslim convert who is legally
married to four wives uh send the
remaining three if he send away the send
well send okay there if he is newly
converted or should he keep them uh so
basically he's got wives and children
and he wants to know what to do mhm uh
and and and and can he be uh in right
standing and this particular case you
know this is actual case just like the
man from u i I suppose is from Africa
who s get the question you know there is
this situation where somebody who is not
of the faith who had accepted this
belief or this system that is okay you
know to have many wives turns out that
he believes the truth he gets the gospel
what does he do with those children and
these wives that he has you know should
he send them away should he uh stop
having uh intim intimacy with this his
wives you know what does he do um so you
know I I think I can answer from the
what the and I think Pastor C you can
actually mention this to confirm you
know what I'm going to say but the
general conference sort of established
um parameter that the ideal of God is to
have one you know one wife one man we I
mean we know that that's the experience
and in the case of somebody that is
married currently with several
wives uh they the church has take the
position that he must he cannot just
leave them because they already are his
wives so he is not to divorce them per
se especially in a especially in a
culture where the man is the bread
winner exactly espe will take care of
them no one will pick them up no one
will marry them and he has a duty to you
know to to take care of those wives and
those children these are his children he
needs to take care of them so the the
recommendation or the strong
recommendation is that he only stays
with one wife and the three or four that
he has extra he needs to keep them as
just family but not have any more of a
you know a house husband wife
relationship now that is easy to say I
have I say this easy to say because we
don't experience that and in those
particular cases you know I think it's
going to be hard but that's the
recommendation that the church has upon
people who have been already in a
polygamous relationship where he
continues to prare for the children he's
Li married to them he provides for the
families but he has to elect just one
wife to be his wife you know it's
interesting that uh the Bible has many
cases of individuals that were po
polygamous but clearly it wasn't the
ideal because all the wives ended up
fighting yeah yeah so so polygamy is not
God's ideal uh you know let me just read
the text where God's ideal is in Genesis
CH 2 and verse 24 therefore a man shall
leave his father and mother and be
joined to his wife not wives his wife
and they shall become one flesh of
course we live in a world where not
everything is ideal right and so the the
general conference has uh made a
suggestion to make the best out of a bad
situation correct correct correct it is
it is you know 1 Timothy 58 says if a
man does not provide for his family is
worth an Infidel well that that is your
family you've got children with these
women so you you can't just turn your
back and walk away from them uh
certainly Christ wouldn't want them to
suffer uh but they must be taken care of
you you are doing that anyway right uh
the only difference is now you need to
select one to be your quote wife and the
others you need to continue to support
as you have supported them because there
are many cultures where if if a woman is
turned away with children and whatnot
she's not going to get any support her
parents will not take her back or maybe
they cannot afford to take her back uh
and then She's suffering uh needlessly
so um make the choice make the decision
and then follow follow through maybe uh
what needs to happen is that the family
of the individual who has multiple wives
and children can kick in in to help
because financially it's a very heavy
burden you know to provide for four
wives say and who knows how many
children right so you know at at that
point
uh family members have to kick in and
help in that situation and there are
some you know uh cultures I just had a
friend who visit um a country in in in
Africa and he mentioned that a lot of
the women were the W The Bread Winners I
mean they were actually the ones that
work even more so than the men and you
know and it's interesting to see that
perhaps the experience of some of these
places where they have these you know
these things have made uh even though
they're supposed to be the men that
takes care of the families and what not
the conditions have made necessary for
women to also work and sustain
themselves and so uh I think that you
know the main thing is we keep uh
looking for them reaching out to them
and I don't know if the question about
being baptized or not I mean I think
that anybody should be able to be
baptized understanding what needs to be
taken care of his you know his family
but uh as we mentioned the polygamus
have of course hope they are to come to
the Lord and to receive the the teaching
and the blessing of being part of the
Gospel being part of the family of the
church uh the only thing that I could
say is that the scriptures mentions in
second in 1 Timothy chapter 3 that
for a man to be a bishop or a deacon or
something like that you need to have one
wife so I guess that would be to me the
only thing that biblically a person who
is in po polygamy who has accepted the
new understanding and he has kept
himself you know just with one one wife
even though he has support other wives
maybe he's not able to have that
position in church but he can certainly
be part of the Fellowship of the church
um if if he has accepted you know the
truth and just made his put his life in
order um that's what I I would say in to
this question finally El do you have
anything else I don't have any more
inspiration the thing that occurs to me
is one that that God loves you so don't
ever think you're outside of hope some
of these decisions are going to be tough
they're not going to be easy coming to
Christ is is not always an easy thing
but God is in there with you he's trying
to get you in not keep you out uh he
loves you he he cares for you he cares
about all your wives and all of your
children you've got to some tough
decisions to make but know and rest
assured that you do not make them alone
pray seek the advice of people who know
the Lord and love the Lord and I'm sure
the Lord will lead you because he's
promised to do so and to answer the
prayer of faith that we believe and that
we know so God bless you as you wrestle
with some of these tough problems uh
that just come up as we live our lives
here on this Earth well our time has
fast slipped into eternity allow me now
on closing again to wish you both Grace
and peace through our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ we'll see you again soon on
this very bro broadcast bye-bye and God
bless shalom
[Music]